one of our organizer the Rhine Center
able to talk about data no data director
you can get FDA and I did it the right
point wise convergence so yeah so this
is our joint work with benkert Alec and
wojtek and think benkert and wojtek us
probably some it here so oh they so
hopefully this is a fun topic like it
started off as an observation in a
different problem that we are looking at
and it's sort of acquired a life of its
own so let's begin with an example it's
a simple universal set up there's a
class of models and B sample I ID from
some unknown model in the class and we
are looking at cases where or each of
the distributions in the model in the
moderate class is over a countably
infinite alphabet okay what we want to
do is we want to find an upper bound on
all percentiles of the distribution what
is a percentile the half percentile is
the median or so the one minus Delta
percentile is just this point where the
cumulative distribution function of the
underlay I mean where the CDF becomes 1
minus Delta okay so essentially we want
to upper bound all the percentiles so we
want to find this we do know this red
curve but we want to estimate a green
curve okay which is come so that the red
curve completely dominates the green one
okay so that way we have a finite upper
bound on all percentiles if F hat is
also a cumulative distribution of some
this one okay so essentially this is the
task we want to find we have an unknown
distribution we want to find an upper
bound on all percentiles okay are so
very simple or what do we Benes it good
well if we do find out if we do find a
curve green curve that is dominated by
the true CDF then everything is good we
say the loss is zero if not if anything
else happens right so the loss
one okay so we want to somehow
simultaneously bound all percentiles we
don't care about what happens at
infinity we don't care when this green
curve it's one it can go to one at
infinity that we don't care okay so so
this is the task and we ask okay we we
keep drawing samples and hopefully our
estimates keep getting refined and we
want to ask like what does happening
right so what are the asymptotics well
like oh yeah outside the values you
reach over thousands right now we just
care about we don't care about how tight
like push the curve way to the right
well like your you want F had to also be
a CDF and way to the right you cannot
push it to infinity because you want
finite upper bounds on all percentiles
right so you can try pushing it as far I
mean you can make it rise as slow as you
want right but the question is can you
do even that okay because remember like
we are the idea is to look at classes
with potential even this is going to be
difficult right so you can make it rise
very very very very very slow but it has
to for any threshold if I give you any
threat or like one half it has to hit
one half at a finite time right so the
whole thing is between whether it's
finite or not fine act right now okay so
you can't say okay this is going so slow
at a zero and it goes to one at infinity
that does not allowed but anything else
you can make it rise as low as you want
that's okay okay right so okay so what
are the kinds of guarantees the thing
that are be like usually is that there
is you look at the supremum of the loss
okay and the supremum of the loss goes
to zero but then like this is not
terribly interesting why's that because
if the supremum of the loss goes to zero
it's a 0 1 loss function it means from
some point on your loss 40 forever which
means there is some cdf that is
dominated by all the pier
CDF's in the class okay so why look at
the data you can just start off with
this okay so this says so this just
means that the class p is tight there
isn't finite upper bound on every
percent i just start off with this
finite upper bound because we don't ask
how we don't care about how good the
approximation how good the upper bound
is we just want to find out upper bound
right so it's this part clear by the way
is to be random there's no expectation
like because we have P we have an
estimate are right so our be we haven't
qualified exactly how this goes to 0 in
this one bite okay let's say it will be
looking at almost sure convergence so
yeah so if for any action actually for
any sequence you can manage this it
means there's a CD of the dominant so
why do all this like just start off with
that right so so we look at something a
little different okay so we just require
that our estimate eventually upper
bounds these CDF's of the underlying
distribution the convergence is almost
surely but there's no uniform
convergence okay so this is a little
more interesting because it need not
happen that all the CDF's of the class
dominate some Universal CDF okay so
somehow you need to learn something from
the data okay and if you can do it let
us say you can even do this okay the
question we are going to ask is
something are something that qualifies
the statement and it's something every
parent knows so the question is are we
the area right so eventually eventually
you know that you are going to do well
okay so assuming assuming that I even
tell you that the unknown FP will
dominate your estimate eventually almost
surely the question is with the data you
have how do you know how well you are
doing ok so that is sort of the crux of
what
we want to answer okay so given just
this data can we say is a point wise
consistent estimate good or not okay so
essentially we have a series of results
which we'll go over in the talk so this
is a lot of work that spans like the
last two and a half years so for
prediction and come and compression be
completely characterized when we can
answer this question when it is possible
to answer the question will show how
okay are there are which also means that
there are cases where you cannot give a
answer to this question will see an
example very shortly okay also like what
happens is like when you ask when you
require that when you go away from just
asking for pointwise consistent
estimators you also want you demand that
in addition to a point wise consistent
estimate you also should be able to tell
when you start doing well it changes
some things number one or everything
depends now on how the property varies
in the model class okay so you look at
any model in your model class it doesn't
matter how vast your entire classes can
know global property matters what
matters is around the model how does the
property very so you it's like the lot
of rich people in the world right Bill
Gates this very rich but you just want
to be richer than your neighbor right so
it's that way so you're just looking
locally you don't care about global
properties anymore okay so they it
changes the focus when you ask that when
you demand that you need to know from
the data however you are doing it's it's
also related to the question of
robustness of priors which a lot of
patients look at we won't go over that
we won't have time for all that but just
a say aside okay so at a high level yeah
random stopping here where you stop
right so will formalize that so yeah
there has to be like a universal
stopping time are the you mean this
stopping time obviously cannot
on the unknown distribution it should be
universal for the entire class and it
should somehow in indicate accurately
that this is the point at which your
accuracy something will come to that
yeah so any other questions okay so what
we will do is this like we look at a
simple example where you cannot answer
this question okay so mainly because our
it sort of will make it clear like what
is at play here so this is an example
that we call as hiding of entropy okay
why is it because we are looking at a
class of distributions like this you
assign 1 minus epsilon 20 and the
remaining epsilon probability you
distribute among em elements okay now
epsilon can be made as small as you want
okay epsilon can be zero as well but
epsilon can also be made as small as you
want but when you make epsilon to be a
very very tiny nonzero quantity you can
still make capital M large enough that
you can hide as much in Tropius you want
in this state right so are so our task
is to estimate the entropy and this tale
will hit us okay so what first thing is
there are no uniformly consistent
estimates it's not hard to see it's also
easy to see that every distribution in
this class has a finite support okay so
if you just base your estimate of
entropy on the empirical of frequencies
okay this one is almost surely going to
be consistent okay the estimate of
entropy purely from the empirical
frequencies will be almost surely
consistent because every distribution as
a finite support okay the question we
are going to ask is so what we are going
to observe like it almost sounds like a
poem but da it's something like this
there are some cases where you never be
able to tell how good your estimators ok
so I started writing this and yes so so
let R be any no I I tried making it into
something more interesting by then I was
too sleepy so
so okay so it let not be any number
however large ETA V any confidence
however small like you look at a
sequence essentially it's like this you
look at a sequence of zeros right a long
sequence of n zeros you can never claim
or no matter what you estimate of
entropy is you can never claim you're
anywhere close to the true entropy why's
that look at the sequence of zeros with
the so there is this distribution right
which assigns probability 1 to 0 and 0
everywhere else this gives this
distribution let's call this p naught
and then there are distributions where
epsilon is really really tiny much much
much smaller than 1 over N right but M
is bigger than let's say due to the are
over epsilon okay so what is the entropy
of this source it is bigger than epsilon
log m which is bigger than our right are
but this source because epsilon can be
made as small as you want right this
also gives
you can make it as close to one as you
want by picking epsilon as small as you
want right so because there is no bound
on em right you can hide all the entropy
in detail right then because 1 minus
epsilon is very very close to one this
sequence gets very high probability so
with hype so you cannot no matter what
your estimators right it cannot be close
to both 0 and are right so you can never
get and are can be completely arbitrary
okay so on this sequence of zeros you
will never be able to tell if you are
doing well or not okay even though you
know that like the plug-in estimate
which estimates 0 as the entropy will
eventually be a consistent because like
but then after any finite amount of time
there's nothing you can tell so
essentially the phone but there are a
lot of classes so that's what we will
see this is not this is nothing to do
with just uniform a lot of cases even
with pointwise consistent estimates that
you can still tell from the data what is
happening so it's a different thing from
the right so it's not a question of just
uniform and pointwise consistency like
even in point wise consistency will see
fairly complicated classes where are
there is no simple uniform consistent
estimator but you can still tell from
the data how well you are doing okay
this is like how the Bayesian sometimes
say that the data dominates the prior
something like that in that principle
yeah example for this example which was
this is a negative example right so this
is a case where on this sequence of
zeros let which is which happens with
probability 1 under the singleton source
this source okay you under this source
with probability 1 you can never tell if
you're doing well or not no matter what
your estimators okay so you have a case
where you have
consistent estimation is possible but
you are never able to tell at least for
this source you are never able to tell
how well you are doing ok so this is
what we want to resolve we want to ask
when can you say how well you are doing
and when cannot you say however you are
doing ok we want for every source right
so in a sense this example is chosen
because it is simple it's kind of
pathological because you remove this one
source everything works now but we're so
this is a pathological example but we
also many other cases like our most
prominent being limp as a source codes
right we know that for mark our sources
of any memory Lempel Ziv code length is
asymptotically optimal but if i give you
like a 10,000 length sequence and ask
you against the true source not against
a Markov source with memory k I ask you
against the true source what is the
redundancy this means that you need to
have some idea of what the order of the
Markov sources ok and that is a much
harder problem and in general like there
isn't much you would be able to say
right so that is it's along the same
principle here we are looking of course
at iid data we are not looking at
something or as even as complicated as
memory because we just want to highlight
this particular principle ok oh right
haha system so it says more source seems
like the limiting point a lot for the
other sources right oh this in this case
your right leg so this source we call it
as a deceptive source because it sort of
fools you into making an estimate while
something else nearby hits you tonight
so it's sort of cheating you so our but
then like car in many classes like
including monotone distributions for
example like every source behaves like
this deceptive source okay so okay so
the point is like something like
pointwise consistency it has two flavors
where we can tell from the data how well
we are doing and where we cannot right
so what we ask is this
in addition in addition to the estimate
which may be / which is pointwise
consider consistent we want a stopping
rule ok so this stopping rule sort of
indicates when is it safe for you to say
you're accurate ok so this stopping rule
are so there is one stopping rule for
the entire class ok so there's one
stopping rule so it is universal for the
entire class it sort of so is the
stopping rule has taught means that your
estimate has started doing well ok so
the bad thing is you're stopping rule
has stopped but your estimate is still
not accurate enough ok that's the bad
news ok so for example how would we
phrase it for the prediction problem oh
excuse me so we want a stopping rule
such that the rule has stopped but you
still are not doing well this
probability should be bounded with any
confidence that I give you ok so this is
the bag this is the bad event because
you're stopping rules somehow indicates
that you are accurate but in fact you're
not ok so this is the case where you
haven't you're stopping rule hasn't been
able to be hasn't been able to tell you
the accurately whether or not you're
doing well ok so the this bad event we
wanted to be as small as possible ok so
we call this if you can do this we call
the class insurable the reason is I'll
give you a puzzle at the end and you'll
see why we use that word insurable ok
you can do something very similar for
compression as well or in compression
your loss via your loss does not
converge almost surely 20 here it
converges in l1 in me are but are but
it's like an unconventional rephrasing
of the regular redundancy things are
uniform uniform where if this
convergence is uniform then it means
it's strongly compressible with
asymptotically 0 per symbol redundancy
where it's not it's like Kieffer's beak
universality ok so we'll focus on just
one those so
right so going back to the insurability
we'll just focus on this because I don't
think we have time to ask for both so
going for this it's actually a very easy
to say like what exactly must be
satisfied for you to be able to tell
from the data how well you are doing ok
so it's like a true thism like around
every model there is a simple
neighborhood ok that's what you need
that is both necessary and sufficient
for you to be able to tell from the data
how well you are doing ok what does this
mean are well like simple depends upon
exactly the property you're estimating
we'll see what happens for the
insurability case in just a little bit
right so ah but some couple of points
this simple neighborhood around every
module can be arbitrarily small ok it
doesn't have to be a it did need to be I
mean it has to be nonzero but as long as
it is nonzero the tiny simple
neighborhood around any class can be as
little as you want it doesn't matter ok
also there's no requirement that the
size of this simple neighborhood is sort
of uniform around the across the class
ok so around every p there's a simple
neighborhood ok and if you take the
infimum of all these neighborhoods that
can be 0 although like for any single
model if i look at any single model it
must have a nonzero simple neighborhood
ok so the sizes of these neighborhoods
can vary some neighborhoods can be very
very tiny some neighborhoods can be
large it doesn't matter there's no lower
bound necessary on the size of the
neighborhood as long as it's nonzero so
essentially what is happening here is
like you are looking at a local property
because you're not concerned about how I
mean the class by itself can be very
complex what you are concerned about as
around every model is a neighborhood
simple that's all you care about ok
around every model is some neighborhood
however small is
it simple okay so for the insurability
case are so we have a characterization
like you can tell from the you can
estimate this percentiles from the data
if and only if some neighborhood around
every module is tight okay so in some
tiny neighborhood around the every model
you can do the problem trivially okay so
this R so this is this is sort of the
flavor no matter what property you seem
to consider that for compression for
example you have something very similar
like around every model you need a small
neighborhood that is strongly
compressible ok so the your entire class
need not be strongly compressible they
redundancy can be infinitely nothing
matters ok around every module is the
neighborhood strongly compressible that
the neighborhood can be as small as you
want ok so that's the only thing that
seems that would matter for data-driven
characterizations ok so how do we do
this like it's a constructive proof
which I'm happy to talk about our
offline or so but it's essentially like
we exploit the fact that we are looking
at countable alphabets and so we have so
we have this class any class of models /
naturals has a Lindelof property so we
managed to cover the entire class with a
countable number of small good
neighborhoods and that sort of the
flavor of how we construct this game ok
so going back to our what classes can
you actually are what classes can you
predict for example ok so the class of
all distributions all uniform
distributions ok right so the class of
all uniform distributions for example
that is insurable this is not so strange
because you look at sample from a
uniform distribution you play Europe you
can predict the value for the next
sample as twice the maximum so far and
that's going to be more and more
accurate as the number of some
goes to infinity right a minute
exponentially first okay so this is not
so strange there is a more interesting
class like we take uniform distribution
but we place a tail on them the stale
can be arbitrarily fat tails okay it can
diminish us close one over N 1 over N
log n cubed okay ah but even in these
cases like so these so when you talk
about being able to predict from the
data how well you are doing you're not
implicitly restricting yourself to a
fast tails or I mean you don't need your
distribution to have I mean you can
still have your distribution having
heavy tails ok so again like it means
like you you don't care about like
whether the tales of fact or not if I
distribution has a fate fact I'll you
just care about whether the surrounding
distributions are similar or not okay so
so essentially like we can actually
predict or even when you have very very
fat tails they have arbitrarily long
uniform distributions followed by a very
very slow or diminishing tails okay so
and it's actually pretty interesting to
compare how these properties are hold
and this is the last light so how the
properties hold when you look at
compression and ensure insurability so
this is strongly compressible classes
which we are currently focusing on are
the sizes of the boxes are a property of
xfig it's not an indication of how large
classes sir okay so but what word gets
us so we are going away from this little
green box and insurable classes are a
much broader classes and there are
interestingly classes that where you can
predict but you can never come press
there are classes where you can compress
but you can never predict there are
there is everything in between as well
right so are so i'll i can go over all
of this offline if anyone is interested
i'll be here are for this week next week
and again from april 15
the end of the program so thank you yeah
I lucky yeah lucky is a matter of
perspective because like max said it
means you have to get up early yeah that
is true question any questions question
your perspective Weaver I mean hike
one-time experience no no so the so I'm
not actually familiar with the this one
but da to the extent of seen like I've
seen people do similar things in
compression like particularly they have
this notion of hierarchical compression
where you nest classes of models and you
want redundancy to be actually
comparable to the particular class the
source belongs to but then the question
we are asking there is sort of
complementary because we don't care if
the redundancies just come are correct
we want to know what the redundancy is
so the identity of the class level is
what we are asking about so but but we
can talk about the Sam I'll be very
interested in knowing this so yeah okay
since we're rolling into the discussion
so if we can leave the questions to
discussion all set yeah okay so we can
write to the discussion so two things
we're going to go for our lucky talk
again tomorrow so since a lot already
use this trick about tricking students
to help out last time so i can use the
same trick today so what I do hey along
so who's going to help me out it was
below turkey and you know
and let's get a bunch of chairs so chair
set up the front